this tutorial is an overview of the
different ways you can manage your
references using a variety of software
programs that we support at Columbia
libraries we refer to this software as
citation management or bibliographic
management software
examples are endnote refworks and zotero
the Columbia libraries has purchased
site licenses to end their in refworks
so they are free for current columbia
students faculty and staff Sottero is a
free open access product we offer
workshops each semester in these
programs these programs allow you to
import citations easily from cleo and
library databases create large
bibliographies that you can sort edit
and annotate format papers with
footnotes endnotes or in-text citations
format bibliographies collect PDF
screenshots images and other files which
you can tag organize and manage large
sets of information and share it with
others all three programs have different
features and strengths depending on your
needs
so you'll want to know a little about
them before choosing which one is right
for you they are all compatible with
each other and you can move citations
from one to the other so you may want to
use more than one of these programs we
suggest you look at the product
tutorials for each software program to
get a better idea of what they do and
whether or not they appeal to you and
remember the libraries offers hands-on
workshops on these programs each
semester
EndNote is best for large research
projects with dissertations it is the
best of the three programs and handling
large numbers of citations offers the
most options for customizing output
styles and formats provides the best
environment for managing and working
with collected citations represents the
best long-term storage solution of the
three programs for large collections of
citation information but it is also the
most difficult to master and must be
downloaded to your hard drive current
students faculty and staff at Columbia
can download a Windows or Mac version of
EndNote to their hard drive for free to
learn more about using this program see
the n-no tutorial refworks is web-based
software so there's no need to download
the program but you may want to download
the site and write plug-in it is the
best program if you need to access your
citations from anywhere your collections
of citations and references are
available to you on the Internet
this makes refworks most easily
accessible of the three programs
refworks import supports citation import
from the largest number of library
databases one significant strength of
refworks is that you can share your
citations with others however it is the
least satisfactory of a3 as a writing
tool to learn more about its features
see the refworks tutorial
so taro is a free Firefox extension that
lives in your browser it's the easiest
of the three to learn and is a free
open-source product for the databases
that Zotero supports it offers the
simplest import solution it provides an
easy way to capture index and search
full text it is by far the best program
for capturing content and citations from
webpages it also automatically downloads
PDFs and allows you to index and search
the text of PDFs but it doesn't work as
well with very large collections of data
since it's still in development there
are some glitches and it doesn't work at
all with some of the major library
databases such as MLA bibliography and
artful text to learn more about its
features see the Zotero tutorial
downloading the software for EndNote go
to WWE mba edu slash library slash
endnote for refworks go to
www.uwec.edu/career individual account
for Zotero go to WWE from your Firefox
browser for more help using any of these
software programs please contact us at
ETS at libraries at CU l dot columbia
edu for more information on our library
workshops cww columbia edu slash library
slash workshops